et maintenant les mêmes messieurs
pour la tour montparnasse infernale
précieux reagan juillet
vous
eric et ramzy bonsoir service tire
larigot pour vous saluer donc on va
faire un peu de promo on y va on y va
donc encore à la honte à bord ont fait
là on fait la tournée d'abord un pardon
la tournée la tournée 2010 exact qui
s'est terminé par un passage à l'olympia
à de l'année dernier le l'année dernière
oui mais c'est de la vieille fromont et
c'est dire si le promoteur 2006 l'on se
rassure tout le monde est au courant on
sortait un film alors on sait comment on
fait
résident en même temps alors quand vous
sortez un film qui est produit par
christian fechner réalisé par charles
nemes qui faisait h qui faisait moins
d'épisodes violations café avant aussi
les héros n'ont pas froid aux oreilles
voilà une godzilla jurassic park mais
s'est vraiment senti faire aussi un très
bon poulet exemple mais aussi le boulet
les metz alors le pitch vous le faites
ouais l'histoire l'histoire du film de
quoi ça parle
le pitch j'ai envie de me marier avec
des trucs bien et dieu sait qu'il
faudrait répondre aux parce que c'est la
promo et tout mais j'ai ensuite ailleurs
un peu de promo pour faire le pauvre
comme il a mis maintenant 20 millions de
francs dont 10 millions pour le film
génial
auteur à nourrir quand même pas à mourir
mourir quand je vais le faire alors si
vous êtes laveur de carreaux à c'est un
honneur qu'il fait je fais le pitch vous
êtes à bord de cars au tour montparnasse
c'est exact et puis vous voyez comme ça
c'est sûr votre nacelle mais faut le
faire un peu mieux ouais parce que la
73e sur votre nacelle a éveillé
stéphanie quai en fête marina mais bon
dans le film s'appelle stéphanie c'est
un film bon et dont vous êtes
extrêmement doit vous être vendus non
c'est comme un film
ouais pareil c'est un peu comme un fou
avec des explosions mais enfin même quoi
et alors vous plaît même à un moment le
défigurant allez allez on y va
êtes-vous vraiment amoureux de stéphanie
wii dont je suis amoureux dans le film
ouais et qui soudainement est prise en
otage
pourquoi par la rue gamelin conseil
d'administration conseil d'animation
très très puissant mais très puissante
les lens va le groupement rival au début
on veut on voulait les appelait les deux
furent sac et est bon apparemment la
marque a refusé de décoller de son image
à nous il trouvait que c'était pas assez
classe alors surtout le mot secte de
fursac c'est super classe
alors 52 francs la place mais là je
crois que c'est la meilleure forme au
ces ce soir c'est vraiment de la john
promo je me connais je te jure que oui
j'ai rien dit c'est bien vraiment promo
les mecs